the setting of speed management rule
requires Council to develop a speed
management plan and consult with the
community the proposed plan focuses on
speed limits around our schools it also
proposes some changes at Key
intersections and a small number of
Roads speed management plans form part
of New Zealand's road to zero strategy
that aims to stop people being killed or
injured on our roads safer speed limits
is just one area of focus where we can
address harm other areas include
improving road conditions and Road s
sites encouraging the use of safer
vehicles and encouraging better driver
Behavior go online for more information
and tell us what you think at wad. govt.
nzl
talk